it gets confusing because because the
the celebration of what she did
i think should be about an athlete is
taking greater control of their life
and not allowing their decisions to be
dictated by
teams or organizations rather than
we're celebrating the fact that she's
opting out
now we're going to get into the simone
biles topic you know obviously
uh winner of 30 combined olympic and
world championships medals best
uh gymnast of all time sure if it's not
her it's nadia so it's one or two
right it's probably her and um
she was in the final the team was in the
finals
and she had a bad vault and then she
left the competition
and and because it's so rare to see an
all-time great
step back from a competition in the
finals with a gold medal on the line
it it inspired a whole wave of
of analysis right and um
one of those the what she was saying is
that it wasn't
right for her mental health to continue
that was the initial statement
and you know she had to protect herself
and she
you know uh stepped back and let one of
the other
girls step in and they got a silver
medal which is
you know still victoria's outcome um but
because because it's so rare to see it
and because we are all conditioned for
the stoicist
idea of champions originally there was
this big outcry
of you know i've never seen someone quit
on that stage blah blah blah
and then there was the backlash to that
no she's doing the right thing she's
she's taking a claim for mental health
um and so it became this kind of
weirdly unmoderated debate and the
subject of many a think piece
um and so where did you where were you
when all this was going on what were you
thinking about all this yeah it's
interesting
and and what's also fascinating about it
is that it became a partisan issue
yeah like everything else it became
politicized and your perspective
on what you know simone biles decided to
do
your perspective on that had to reflect
your political ideology
it didn't seem to a lot you know like me
personally
when i first saw it the first thing i
thought is i've never seen an all-time
great do that
so then i start thinking because i'm a
skeptical journalist so i started
thinking
was she going to lose anyway and she
didn't want to lose this is a way to
lose that without losing
that's where i first went this is not a
judgment on her this is just where
my thought process was and then i
thought
so i thought that then i thought i do
like it when
you know i did feel like she has a team
it's not just an individual
thing that she's stepping back from
that's one thing she does have a team
that's relying on her she's the leader
of the team
so i did fall into that category even
though politically
it doesn't seem like that should be the
place that i line up that was the first
place i did go to
um before kind of taking a step back and
letting it settle
and what kind of convinced me to think
of it differently was when it
came she posted that she actually has
what they call the twisties i guess in
gymnastics
she uh had the yips she couldn't land
yeah if you can't land you can't so
yeah the the way she described it is you
lose your
sense of like space and time so you're
in the middle of like a vault and you're
in the middle of the air and you don't
know which way is
up and which way is down yeah and this
got
played out in those early i think was it
a vault or there was some attempt where
um she intended to do i don't know what
it was like a two and a half two and a
half twist or whatever and only did one
or one and a half and landed
kind of off kilter that was clear
indication like
there was something going on here and
and i agree i think
that original kind of knee-jerk
sentiment is sort of a boomer adjacent
sentiment like us being older right like
what do you mean you're gonna not you're
gonna opt out
right right the very definition of a
champion is the person who
perseveres who demonstrates the grid and
when their back is against the wall
and everything's stacked against them
they they move forward nonetheless and
either prevail or don't yeah that's the
conventional wisdom here and i think
what
what complicates the simone biles
situation
is a couple things first of all when
you're dealing with gymnastics you're
dealing with
um very dire physical consequences if
things go wrong
it's not just hey you know i'm not going
to run this race because i'm not feeling
it it's like if i
land wrong i could land on my neck i
could paralyze myself
and i think second to that there is
um there is truth in that
she was opting out for the best interest
of the team because
if she wasn't going to be able to
perform to her abilities then
is that really in the interest of the
team's quest to win a team medal
right yeah would would that would that
be better filled by somebody else
so there was a self-sacrifice aspect to
it and i think
look you know greatest of all time
30 combined olympic and world you know
world championship
medals this is not somebody this is not
like a wilting
flower like this is somebody who has a
champion mindset
who knows themselves as well as anybody
the level of like self-integration that
you would have to have to perform
you know these routines that she does
it's just it's mind-blowing so this is
not somebody
who is scared of you know obstacles or
difficulties
so when this person says look i need a
break
it's not like there's a history of
simone saying that
right this is new so we should take it
seriously it should be a benefit who do
you think wanted to win the gold medal
more than her nobody tucker crosstalk
checkered carlson wanted it so
i love like you know q pierce morgan you
know who always has
yeah it's like come on dude like all the
peoples
who had the hot take of your your you
know your
your wimping out are all couch potatoes
yes
nobody who's well versed in elite
performance
had that perspective it gets confusing
because
because the the celebration of what she
did
i think should be about the fact that
an athlete is taking greater control of
their life
and not allowing their decisions to be
dictated by
teams or organizations rather than
we're celebrating the fact that she's
opting out for the sake of freaking out
because it politicized and we can get
into that
in a little bit because i have a ted
talk i'd like to unleash it
it's it's first of all it's ridiculous
it's like this was a personal choice she
made
because she had her own calculus and
part of that calculus has to be
the fact that the us gymnastics has been
a corrupt organization that
that included uh uh
child like yeah she suffered abuse she
was abused by
by uh larry nassar the doctor she's one
of the survivors
there were you know what dozens of girls
that were um
that were abused by this man who's now
in prison you know she came back at 24
which is an advanced age in gymnastics
as we all know
and she did that as to to help change
the sport
yeah um and so to when you put all of
that in
into the pot and you stir it up um you
understand these demons are real
it's it like that had to be part of the
thing like should i sacrifice myself
right now
like for who and that had to be part of
it and that doesn't necessarily make it
make it open and shut case because as of
this taping
she is going to compete on the balance
beam she's going back out for one last
uh routine um so she is going to do that
in an individual balance beam
but it had to be part of the situation
that led to
this 60s yeah july 27
being this day you know in 2015 as you
mentioned that was the day
yeah six years ago she was at usag
headquarters in indianapolis for a bunch
of promotional appearances
um and being accompanied by
you know this guy who was well aware of
what was going on
and was working with an fbi agent to
like sweep it under the rug right
promised that that fbi agent would get
some job with
the ioc or something like that i mean
this washington post article is pretty
incredible yeah that's incredible
we'll link that up um in the show notes
but yeah it provides
a much greater more in-depth context for
what's actually going on and when you
think about simone's career
now being an elder statesman which is
hard to believe because she's so young
and the care that she you know
undertakes to like
mentor all of these younger athletes
particularly um
you know athletes of color yeah which is
so important to her
compounded by this idea of being an
elder statesman who
links the legacy of nassar to the
current state of affairs like that's a
that's a lot to shoulder
yeah and twisty's it's not her first
time
no when was it there was some other
incident a couple years ago where she
had twisties it took her a couple weeks
to get over it so
and twisty it's like this real thing
keeping track of your body position i
guess
yeah yeah i guess i mean i'd never heard
of it before no um
but when you really evaluate it you know
and contextualize the whole thing it's
like she made the right decision
for herself and for the team and it's
ballsy as [ __ ]
that she would make that decision given
a great awareness and understanding of
the consequences knowing it's going to
be this big controversial thing
knowing that it's going to cause a media
cycle and a media frenzy
but i think it takes a lot of gumption
and guts to
know what's best for you make that
decision irrespective of what the
reaction is going to be and do it
for the interest of the long term
as opposed to the short term gains that
you might have
reaped by making a different decision
right there are all these
case studies of other gymnasts over the
years
who were pushed push push pushed and
were competing with stress fractures and
broken feet and
all kinds of stuff and get the gold and
then you never see them again
yeah so what are we really talking about
what's more important here
like getting the gold medal at this
olympiad or
you know simone being able to compete
for another four years
and be healthy and more importantly
who gets to make this decision
historically it's the teams or it's
the ioc or it's the usoc
and here we have simone standing on the
shoulders of naomi osaka
and what she did you know last month or
whenever it was
to say like i don't have to be a pawn
i'm not
you know a you know a pony here to dance
for you when you wish like i have
sovereignty over myself and my career
and
i'm going to put my foot down and say
i'm not competing it's not right for me
and they should have the right to make
that decision you know and doing it
in the face of all these other pressures
like as a young nobody
like how dare you judge simone you don't
know what's going on in her head you
can't
imagine the pressure that she's
shouldering or her
interior experience of being in tokyo
and everything that's going on
around her with the whole world focused
on her that's right
this is a conversation that we've been
having on the show for a long time that
started with the weight of gold and the
michael phelps documentary and this
growing awareness around the reality of
you know the mental interior experience
of the elite athlete
and kind of pulling covers on that and
helping people to understand that these
are human beings
i mean yeah first probably first person
on your podcast that brought this
particular conversation up right i mean
yeah i mean i've had and we've had you
know alexi pappas has talked to
we've had tons of people talking about
this and so then
uh but brad's article uh talks about
this concept of heroic individualism
which is
you know that's why we worship athletes
and he's like his his point was though
there's a there's an innate problem with
worshiping the athlete and that is that
you're buying into heroic individualism
which is a game of one-upmanship against
yourself and others
and everyone has that in in western
societies his argument
um it's it's it's basically baked into
western society
i know as a writer i feel it you know i
feel that for real i feel it in myself
when i'm working on something i feel it
uh in competition even with friends and
you know i feel it
and that that's i don't feel good about
it like it's not a positive
experience and you you feel like you
feel it you don't want to really
buy into it but it's there um and so his
point was
you know she made the right choice but
sometimes the right choice
would be to persevere through it so yeah
his is a much more nuanced
situation and he looks at kind of the
the the science on
on depression and and these mental
health issues the biggest
reveal of all this is not necessarily
her mental state and what she's got to
do for herself because i think when it
comes down to it
you're 100 right um
especially simone biles deserves the
benefit of the doubt especially in
all-time great if you're going to
worship athletes yeah
then you have to give an all-time great
the benefit of the doubt
and like if that's what this person
needs then that's what that person needs
does that make her her hero not
necessarily but it makes her
human and so that's the point and that's
the tension right
like we don't want our our heroes to be
human right
and this is a conversation about
recognizing the inherent humanity in the
elite athlete
but also the olympics is there is
something to be
gained from and something to be said for
like holding people up a little bit
higher
as benchmarks to you know kind of drive
our own aspirations like i want heroes
yeah right so that so heroes aren't cut
out characters like i have to appreciate
that they're actually human and they're
flawed
but i think we all benefit when we
celebrate people who do amazing things
and until we actually heard about the
twisties a couple days later when she
posted it nobody actually knew why she
quit
yeah like no one knew like on the but
that doesn't stop everybody from having
their take or opinion
or pierce morgan from getting up and
bloviating
and then discord feeds discord because
yes piers morgan and people on the right
had that
take but on the left we do it too i mean
the left
rails against criminal justice system
and harsh sentences unless it's the cop
that murdered george floyd
the right loves cops wants to make love
to the constitution
unless we're talking about the 2020
election and inspectionists on january
6th i mean
exactly it's everything it's just what's
politically expedient
yeah the narrative bends to bends to the
you know the political ambition exactly
and
you know personal freedom for trans
people is good personal freedom for
anti-masters not good or vice versa you
know it's like it's like
it's one side stakes out of position the
other screams and yells
and on the left you better scream and
well yell exactly the right way
because if you don't you're just a
little bit out of step you're gonna get
you're gonna be torched and and we need
a new culture you know we need
not only do we not want to buy into
heroic individualism we need to replace
this me me me me with we over me and if
that starts with conversations
uh you know the favor my favorite moment
of the olympics so far
are the two high jumpers from qatar in
italy who were who had both tied
and they were given an opportunity do
you want to do a jump off and one of you
will be the true olympic champion
or do you want to share a gold medal and
they
they shared the gold medal they hugged
and kissed and it was beautiful
and it's like it's like people love that
and that's great and that makes me feel
good too but also
back to the stoic kind of response like
if you are the gladiator
do you do you accept that you say no we
will
we will fight to the death to figure out
who's better i think russell crowe and
gladiator would have hugged jamon hansu
you think so
yes maybe there hasn't been this kind of
discord
in olympic well i guess there always is
that's not true that's not true
we have 68 with a boycott in 80. 84.
so it's always there's been a political
aspect to all of this
but i feel like now that's drilled down
into
it's it's becoming even more because of
the way that the culture is
the difference is now it's not nations
that are having political infighting or
leaders from from oppressed groups
within a nation
it's it's individuals over [ __ ] it's
not like we're not even talking about
uh you know black power in 1968 at
a time when there was incredible uh
oppression over the end
and they actually risked their gold
medals and gave up their gold medals
knowing
they would do it right we're not talking
about uh 1968.
we're talking about a woman a young
woman making a decision for herself and
then it becoming a political issue
like that was a political issue i know
this is like this is this
isn't a political issue i know it really
isn't i know and then it becomes one
so it's like it's backwards and uh and
you know i think it's upon uh coming
upon us to
want to like get getting back to your
comments like listeners
we gotta all be willing to have
conversations with people who disagree
with us
you know we have to because we're not
going to get anywhere
in solving big problems unless we're
willing to do that so it's interesting
the olympics
showed us another lesson there
[Music]
you